ever andrade dejó las armas en 2017 lo
hizo bajo la promesa de que la
desmovilización de la guerrilla de las
farc de la que formaba parte llegaba
acompañada de financiación estatal para
ayudar en la reincorporación de los ex
combatientes a la vida pacífica ahora
andrade se dedica a recoger hojas de
coca otro oficio ilegal de ley detener
que nosotros grato resto porque tenemos
que agarrar esto porque los los
presidentes que hemos tenido no nos han
dado todavía ninguna ayuda ningún apoyo
la situación de andrade es frecuente en
el catatumbo la región con mayor
cantidad de cultivos de hoja de coca en
el mundo como muchos de los 13.000 ex
combatientes de las antiguas farc cake
que dejaron las armas al siente que el
estado de los estafó entramos al proceso
con esa alegría con esa iniciativa
de que íbamos a haber una colombia nueva
una colombia en paz que íbamos a volver
a estar todos unidos pero pues
el tema de la coca nos hace volver a
nosotros por la necesidad pero desde la
visita del nuevo presidente de gustavo
petro a la zona hay esperanzas renovadas
en la región
vemos con expectativa las palabras del
señor presidente de petro donde dice de
que no va a haber erradicación forzosa
ni fumigación sino de que va a ser algo
concertado con con las comunidades para
él fue para nosotros es de alivio el
pasado viernes cuatro llamó desde el
catatumbo a crear una asamblea de
cocaleros para impulsar la transición
económica y propuso una reforma rural
para lograrlo ya varios campesinos y
cocaleros se han comenzado a reunir en
vista de la voluntad de diálogo
expresada por el nuevo gobierno el
mandatario ha denunciado reiteradamente
el fracaso de la política antidrogas que
durante décadas impulsaron sus
predecesores una lucha que no ha
conseguido que colombia deje de ser el
primer productor de cocaína del mundo y
que ha causado la muerte de miles de
personas